foreign
[Music]
ER and I'm an assistant professor at the
department of molecular genetics and
microbiology at the University of
Florida and I'm very excited to speak
with you today and tell you about the
work we've been doing the lab over the
last few years where we're dissecting
the host pathogen interactions at
mucosal surfaces
so the mucosal surface that I am most
interested in is the intestinal
epithelium and so this is a complex
interface that is made up of a monolayer
consisting of multiple cell types so we
have this very typical structure where
we have these Crypts and Villi where in
the crypts we have our stem cell Niche
which then differentiates to produce all
the other cell types we find within our
intestine
this intestinal epithelial layer it
forms the primary barrier said providing
us from the outside environment and it's
in constant contact with the
ever-present commensaliflora that means
these cells are incredibly amazing
because they're able to tolerate the
presence of this floral remaining
responsive to pathogens
however if they lose this capability of
being able to tolerate this difference
then this dysregulation of this balance
actually can lead to chronic
inflammation inflammatory bowel diseases
and Cancers
and so one of the things that we're
really interested in in the lab is
understanding how these cells detect and
fight virus infections so in general
what happens is that when a virus gets
inside a cell it's recognized by a
pathogen recognition receptor or a prr
and these can be either in the cytoplasm
or an endosomes after being recognized
by a PR this elicits a signaling Cascade
that product that makes the induction of
type 1 and type 3 interferons these
interferons are then made by those cells
they are then secreted and they can bind
back to the infected cell in an
autocrine manner or the bystander cells
in a paracrine manner binding of these
type 1 and type 3 interferons to their
receptors then elicits the second
signaling Cascade the results in the
nuclear translocation of a special
complex that then induces the interferon
stimulated genes or isgs these isgs can
then come back and act in an antiviral
function in order to try and block
further virus replication however what
you will see as I go through the talk
viruses have also developed
countermeasures in order to block this
induction and sensing of interferons
and so while over the past years ever
people have been developing and looking
at these kind of questions in these
cells one of the things that has
happened is that people have really been
looking at these tissues as a whole and
not really as individual stealth types
and so one of the things that we've been
really interested in is really trying to
go back and look and see what is
happening individually in the cells
within this tissue and some work that's
come out over the past few years has
indicated that stem cells in these stem
cell niches are acting differently than
the other cells in this population where
stem cells appear to be intrinsically
resistant to virus infection there's
also been some work showing that induced
pluripotent stem cells can express these
interferon stimulated G's or isgs but in
an interferon independent Manner and so
this really bring up a lot of questions
to us what how do stem cells in the gut
respond to Virus Infection compared to
differentiated cells and can we actually
infect our stem cell Niche and what
would be the consequence of that in a
virus infection and so to answer these
questions questions we've done three
main things which I will talk about
today so we've exploited human colon and
ilium derived organoids to start to
study enteric virus infectious disease
we've used single cell methods to then
identify which cell types were infected
by these viruses to understand viral
tropism and we've also use single cell
sequencing and RNA fish to characterize
cell type specific intrinsic innate
immune responses generated by these
infections and so the first virus I'm
going to talk about today is going to be
sarskoff 2 and I will talk about a
second virus later on in the talk and so
as everybody has known over the last few
years from the pandemic SARS Cop 2 is
not just a respiratory disorder it can
also affect the brain the heart the
blood vessels liver kidneys and what has
been most interesting to me is the
intestine and so the these reports
started coming out very early on so even
in Wuhan in January of 2020 there was
many people that were having this novel
virus that were experiencing
gastrointestinal symptoms and that's how
I basically got into looking at SARS
cough 2 and its infection of the
intestine
and so over the last years there's been
more and more studies looking at
patients with GI symptoms and a fraction
of covid-19 patients do have GI symptoms
and this can range anywhere from 40 to
70 percent of patients depending on the
study that and the location that has
been done
there are a fraction of patients that
have SARS cog2 genome detected in the
feces so this means that there is virus
being come coming out in the feces and
what's been interesting as well is that
there's a lot other Studies have shown
that patients even though they become
negative in their oropharyngeal swabs so
anything respiratory has become Negative
they maintain genome in the feces for a
very extended period of time and some
things have even shown that people are
secreting SARS Cop 2 and the feces up to
several months after being negative in
oropharyngeal swabs
there is evidence for sarskov 2
replication in GI biopsies these are
more limited off but this is often due
to the technical difficulty in being
able to get a biopsy exactly in the
place that you need to and being able to
catch the replication at the key point
and one of the most controversial thing
is whether or not there's actually
infectious SARS Cop 2 in the feces and
So currently there's no real clear data
that has shown that you can actually get
an infectious virus other than just
genome and there's still studies going
on trying to understand if the virus
itself is infectious or if it's just
shedding genome um at this time
and so the work in the lab that we've
been doing in the model system we're
using our in human mini gut organized so
for us we derive our organoids from
patients biopsies or resections so we
get patient derived material from this
we isolate the stem cell Crypt this
Crypt is then seated into Machu gel and
given differentiation factors and then
over several days it's allowed to seal
and reform and what you can see in this
uh black and white image here in the
center is an actual what an actual
organoid would look like with a light
shell a light sheet microscope and the
reason we like to use this as our model
is because these cells are primary and
non-transformed so we don't have to
worry about having any sort of cancer
phenotypes interfering with our readouts
they can recapitulate the cellular
complexity of the intestinal epithelium
so these are cells are not just made up
of one cell type but they're multiple
cell types they have the structural
Arrangements like we see in the
intestine they also have mucus and other
components that give it a much more in
viewable feel than a normal cell culture
they can also be genetically modifiable
so we can knock out
reagents in it we can also over Express
things in them and they can be patient
specific so we can also look at specific
patients or people that have a certain
condition to see if they're more
susceptible to Virus Infection as well
and so the first train that I've been
using for all the studies are the bath
path too so this was an original isolate
from February of 2020 the wood we took
um neural nasal orophone geoswabs from
infected patients and we isolated the
virus on Vero cells and then what we
first wanted to do was just look at how
this virus infected our human intestinal
organoids so we seeded our organoids
into 2D to allow the apical side to be
able to be accessible for the virus we
then infected them and 24 hours later we
evaluated infection by
immunoflorescence or qpcr
and what we could see first with the
uniflorescence here so um the end
protein is the viral n protein so this
is shown in red the J2 is a
double-stranded RNA antibody that looks
at virus replication and if we look at
the merged image we can see that in our
cultures we have a nice amount of cells
that are expressing viral protein and
viral replication complexes
if we then quantify that we can see from
multiple donors that we get about a
similar amount of infection depending on
the the donor we can also see if we do
qpcr for this we can also get a nice
virus genome increase the virus is
actually replicating in this tissues and
then what we wanted to do is look and
see if the cells are responding to the
virus infection so we looked at the
upregulation of type 1 and type 3
interferons and interestingly what we
could see is that human intestinal
epithelial cells were producing and
secreting interferons in response to
SARS pop 2 infection
we next wanted to go on and see that
these interferons that were being
produced by the cells if they were able
to then block the virus infection
so to do this we seeded ourselves and
then we added interferons to either type
1 interferons or type 3 interferons for
24 hours we then infected with SARS
clock 2 and then we analyzed the
infection 24 hours later with RNA or
immunofluorescence
so first when we look at the immuno
fluorescence we can see here in the
upper right corner our no treatment
shows a lot of infected cells in our
culture so we get this double positive
of our n and our J2 signal however if we
look at type 1 interferons using
interferon beta 1 or type 3 interferons
using interferon lambdas we can see that
we have a great decrease in the amount
of infected cells
and if we quantify this we can see that
we get a drastic reduction in the amount
of infected cells in both type 1 and
type 3 interferon treated samples this
also reduces viral genome replication
when we look at qpcr and it also reduces
the amount of new viruses produced and
we take super Nations and Tighter the
amount of infectious virus being
secreted so we can say that interferons
are able to control SARS [ __ ] 2
replication and spread and the human
intestinal epithelial cells and this
could possibly have some therapeutic
potential and this has been done a lot
in the clinics where there are a lot of
clinical trials using interferons to
block virus infections
so the next thing we wanted to do was
really to go on and then understand
which cell types were infected by SARS
Cop 2 and how they were responding to
the virus so to do this we used our
organoid models we infected them with
SARS cog2 and at 12 and 24 hours
post-infection we dissociated them into
single cells and we used the 10x
genomics platform and from this we were
able to characterize the cell type
specific immune response of the infected
and bystander cells
and so when we did this we actually did
this in both colon and ilium tissues and
for most of the rest of the talk I'm
just going to focus on the colon but we
saw a very similar parallels between
both of them and so when we first did
our U map so our uniform manifold
approximation
approximation and projection we were
able to see that we had about eight
different cell types that are organoid
cultures these then included our stem
cells our goblet cells our introcytes
and showing that we actually had what
cell types we would expect
and so if we then
um look at also these red images on the
side these are our Mock and our 12 and
our 24 hour infected samples and we can
see that they are not changing by a
virus infections so we know that our
organoids are containing our cell types
and that the SARS infection is not
altering the cell type distribution
so we then can go back and look at our
umaps and then plot on these umaps where
SARS Cop 2 is present so you all the
little colored triangles are the cells
that are expressing SARS [ __ ] 2 genome
and so the more yellow the more genome
they're expressing and what you can
notice is that these are in discrete
populations so we're not seeing all cell
types expressing virus genome but we're
seeing them in very small distributions
indicating that this is a more limited
viral tropism
and so if we analyze this and look at
the cell types that is expressing it
what we can see is that we get an
increase in virus infection from 12 to
24 hours but we also see that we have a
main population which is the immature
enterocytes 2 which are supporting the
most infection at both time points so we
can say that we have a restricted
tropism and that SARS cox2
preferentially infects human immature
enterocytes and I just want to point out
here at the top where we have
enterocytes one that we show very very
little infection and this will be
important in the next slide
and so what we wanted to then do is also
to go back and look at the proposed
entry factors and look at how they were
distributed all over these different
cell type populations so here on the
left we have all the different potential
SARS Cop 2 entry factors and on the
bottom we have all of our different cell
type populations and what I showed you
in the previous slide is that immature
enterocyte two were the ones that
supported SARS Cox II infection the best
and the interesting thing that we can
see about this is that H2 expression
which is known to be a key receptor for
SARS Cop 2 is not the thing that will
actually tell us which would be the most
infected cells so if we actually looked
at our enterocyte ones these are the
ones that are displaying the highest
level ace2 and the highest amount of
this receptor so from early on in the
pandemic everybody would have predicted
that these would have been the most
infectable cells but it actually turns
out for us that it seems that this
correlates more with temprest II
expression so we don't have any
correlation that high is 2 means High
infectivity we can see that they are
infected but it's not the only marker
so we also were when we were looking at
um
these
um different markers so ace2 Temperance
to all these different entry factors we
also then wanted to see what happened
over time during infection so in this
plot I again have the on the left hand
side is all of our entry factors or
proposed entry factors and on the bottom
this time we've categorized ourselves
into five different populations so first
we have our mock non-infected cells so
these are cells that have never seen
virus that have just served as our
control we also have then our 12 and 24
hour infected cells that these
populations be broken down into two
different samples so we have not only
um our infected cells we have our
bystander cells so our bystander cells
are anything that is in the infected
population but does not contain a viral
genome so then we can really look at
what the difference is from those cells
that have virus replicating in those
that are just an uh association with it
and interesting what we can see is if we
look at the ace2 levels is that we can
see over time the infected cells are
actually down regulating ace2 so virus
once it gets into the cells it's
actually getting rid of the H2 to also
help prevent from more virus to be able
to come inside and infect
so we then went on to want to look at
what was happening in these cell types
so what kind of immune response was
being elicited in general
so first we took our infected population
and we compared it to our mock
non-infected cells and we looked at a
volcano plot of what were the most
upregulated genes and what we could see
is that in our infected cells we had a
lot of inflammatory components we had a
lot of things with the NF Kappa B tnf
Pathways so really showing this High
pro-inflammatory pathway and however if
we did the same kind of analysis but
this time instead of infected cells we
did our bystander cells compared to our
mock non-infected cells we still have
very different upregulation and these
cells we saw a lot of interferon
stimulated genes and a lot of
interferons so showing that we actually
have an interferon message in bystander
cells but a
pro-inflammatory message in our infected
cells so we can see that they are
actually mounting completely different
and distinct immune responses to SARS
cough too
we wanted to look at this a little bit
more in detail so we again took our five
populations so our infected and
bystander and our non-infected cells and
then we looked at what were the top 10
up regulated genes in each category and
we can see that we got very distinct
responses so again we have our infected
cells showing highly
upregulatedflammatory components where
our bystander cells are showing mostly
isgs and interferon regulating
components we then wanted to go and look
at what are the top 30 up regular isgs
in these cells and then look at them in
our population so here we've selected
our top 30 isgs along the bottom we have
our five different populations along the
side and when we look at this what we
can see is that we have very distinct
um profiles so our infected cells are
pretty much showing no upregulation of
isgs or interferon stimulated genes
where our bystander scales are screaming
in isgs so this analysis has been able
to show us that bystander cells are
responding in a paracrine manner to
interfere on Infected cells mounted
pro-inflammatory response and infected
cells actually seem to become refractive
to interferons because we know
interferons are present we know they're
being secreted but we only see the
bystander cells actually being able to
respond to them and so to be able to
look and see if we actually do see this
refractiveness interferons we did two
different experiments so in our first
experiment what we did is we took
non-infected cells and we treated with
interferons and looked at regulation of
isgs and then we did a combination where
we treated ourselves with interferon in
the presence of sarskopf2 to then
evaluate how much isgs were upregulated
and so when we did this what we could
first see is that SARS Cop 2 on its own
was eliciting very little amounts of
isg-15 which used as a prototypical IHG
for this experiment
if we treated ourselves with interferon
beta we could see that the cells were
capable of responding so the cells can
upregulate this isg and interestingly if
we do a combination of interferon beta 1
and SARS Cop 2 we actually saw a
decrease in the amount of isgs being
produced indicating that SARS Cop 2 is
actually interfering with the signaling
we also did this with another enteric
virus astrovirus and we could see that
this was not the case so astrovirus on
its own was able to upregulate isg-15
interferonic Beta again upregulated in
these tissues and the combination led to
a cumulative effect and not a decrease
showing that this was a SARS cock-2
specific phenotype and then SARS lot
called II infected cells were less
responsive to interferon treatment when
was provided in trends
so we also did a second experiment where
we took some reporter cells that we have
generated and in these reporter cells
when we treat them with interferon we
activate an isg reporter which is mx1
linked to Cherry so when you treat with
interferon cells become red
and if we do this in the presence of
virus infection what we would expect is
that we would get red cells that are
ones responding to interferons we can
stain for virus infection and look at
those infected cells in green and then
we can count for double positives to see
if we can ever get SARS cup two infected
cells that are also isg expressing cells
and so we did this under two different
Moi conditions the first was a high Moi
of three so we got all of our cells
infected and first we started and looked
at our interferon levels so again if we
treat these cells with interferon they
become red they become mx1 positives we
know these cells are responsive when we
have a high amount of SARS [ __ ] 2 we can
see that all the cells are virus
positive and when we do this with SARS
cock-2 and interferon we see that pretty
much all cells are just virus positive
and have blocked any interferon
signaling or any mx1 inductions we don't
see double-positive cells
if we do this at a lower MRI to show
that we can have responsive cells that
are just not virus we can see again that
our interferon is able to elicit mx1
positive cells we get virus positive
cells when we infect ysar's Cop 2 alone
and when we do the combination when we
add mx1 we just increase the amount of
mx1 but we don't increase any double
positive cells so this again showing
that
infected cells are not able to
respond to interferon when provided in
trans but bystander cells are the ones
that are actually responding to
interferon
so this then brings us to our model
where we have our intestinal epithelial
cells that are capable of supporting
SARS Cop 2 infection this is mainly done
by Immature enterocytes and upon Virus
Infection you get secretion of cytokines
but these cytokines just act in a
bystander manner in a paracrine manner
to the neighboring cells and is not
going back and impacting that and
sarskop2 is then also down regulating in
its ace2 receptor to make sure that no
other viruses are getting in
so with that I would like to move to
then a different virus so we were doing
similar analysis at the time but looking
at a different virus to see how this was
impacting and what how different viruses
were affecting these cell types so the
other virus we used was estrovirus so
this is also entered virus model so when
you become infected with astrovirus you
have vomiting stomach ache diarrhea this
is a positive strand RNA envelope virus
non-envelope virus it's an enteric
pathogen for children elderly and immune
compromised patient and it also can be
very important for the poultry industry
and there's a lot of problems that
happens when chickens get infected with
astroviruses
and additionally it's also been shown
that astroviruses are able to infect
several cell types within the human
intestinal tract so first we want to
validate this so we took our organoids
and we infected them with astrovirus and
then we did immunofluorescent staining
to show that they could support
infection and so what you can see in
this bottom panel here is that laminin
is going to Mark our basal lateral
membrane actin is going to Mark our
apical membrane and then the astrovirus
is shown here in green and so what we
can see is that we have a nice organoid
a nice intact organoid and that they're
supporting the infection or replication
of astrovirus
we then wanted to go in and characterize
this a little bit better so we did a
couple different essays so first we used
qpcr to look at viral genome application
and we could see over 24 hours we were
getting an increase in virus genome if
we look at the induction of type 1 and
type 3 interferons we can also see that
we were getting an increase in both of
those over time so we can see the Astro
viruses inducing a type 1 and 3
interferon response in our intestinal
organoids we then wanted to characterize
what cell types were infected by
astrovirus so to do this we used an RNA
scope approach where we took our
infected organoids we seeded them and
infected them with astrovirus for 4 and
16 hours we then froze them in OCT and
sliced sections of them and then we did
serial rounds of RNA fish hybridization
so we did three rounds of four different
colors in each round were quenching
between each hybridization and
amplification and imaging and this
allowed us to then do a 12 pack 12 Plex
picture of these cell types and what you
can see here so we were able to then
look at not only astrovirus genome which
is shown here in the bottom corner but
we also had markers for all other cell
types in the population that allowed us
then to go back and overlay and then
quantify how many co-localizations we
had between the astrovirus genome and
other cell types so as you can see here
astrovirus very highly regulates with
mki 67 cells so with highly
proliferating cells it also has some
co-localization with other markers like
Fab B6
and so we then went and did this for
many different organoids and many
different images and Quantified all of
them and what you can see here is that
we're looking for the bars that are in
Red so when we look at four hours and 16
hours we can see that there's not a lot
of infected cells but we at four hours
at 16 hours we can see that stem cells
nicely support astrovirus infection if
we look at goblet cells we also see nice
infection at 16 hours and if we use two
Market interest sites we also see at 16
hours we have a nice amount of infection
co-localizing with these markers so we
can say that astrovirus infects all cell
types in our human intestinal organoids
we then applied our uh 10x genomics
approach to this as well so using the
similar platform as before where we took
our organoids infected with astrovirus
at 4 and 16 hours post-infection we
dissociated them into single cells and
we put them in the 10x platform
and so then when we do this for this
time I'm showing you the u-map with just
the astrovirus genome so what you can
see that's very different from what we
had with SARS is that we actually see
astrovirus genome everywhere and we see
a lot of areas that are highly lighting
up with astrovirus now if we do this
analysis so unlike SARS where we only
have one that supported the infection we
can actually see that astrovirus infects
all cell types that we have present in
our intestinal organoids and they all
support it to about an equal amount
so then we wanted to go back and look at
how each of these cell types are
responding to infections so before we
looked at infected versus non-infected
because we only had one main cell type
now we have many cell types so we're
able to say how does a stem cell respond
to reply respond to astrovirus compared
to an interest site and so this is what
we did so we right now I'm just showing
you three of our um ones that we looked
at so we have enterocytes stem cells and
trans amplifying cells and just looking
at the non-infected to the infected ones
of these and interesting what we could
see is that were a few things that were
similar so we had something like isg15
which was found in all cell types
however when we started looking more
closely we only saw our classical isgs
were showing up in our intro sites and
all of our other populations were
upregulating different genes were
different than our classical isgs so we
then went back to our bioinformatic
analysis and we then wanted to look and
see if there was a cell fact cell type
specific ISD induction by astrovirus
so what we did is we asked our
bioinformatician to not look at cell
types but just cluster cells based on
stem on their isg expression and when
they did this what we could find is that
we would get four different clusters so
we ended up having this cluster one here
that's on the left width that's all red
cluster 4 here is an um purple and if we
then plot out what are the isgs in each
of these we can see that they're very
distinct so our cluster 4 if we go back
and map them to cells these are intro
sites they have this classical isg
pattern where our cluster one as our
stem cells and these are showing
completely different isg patterns we
then want to go and look at this to see
if this was true not just in infected
cells but also in our basal levels so we
took our mock cells and asked our
bioinformatician to do the same thing
and again we showed a very similar
pattern so we have these red cells on
the left again are stem cells and our
purple and blue ones on the right are
our enterocytes and we can see that
we're having completely distinct isg
inductions showing that the stem cells
and enterocyte is a completely different
way of detecting a virus infection
and so to prove this we went back to our
RNA fish approach where we took of M4 as
our stem cell marker ccl2 as our isg
marker and the astroviro genome and we
looked at this at 16 hours
post-infection and what we can see here
on the bottom images is that our ofmos
for stem cells are expressing our ccl2
in response to astrovirus and if we
quantify this for our other cell types
we can see that this is a stem cell
specific response so we have actually
cell lineages that are responding
completely differently to Virus
Infection than other ones
so in summary what I showed you for this
part is that different cell types in the
intestinal tract Mount distinct innate
immune responses upon enteric virus
infection that we actually see stem
cells and differentiated cells have
different basal levels of isgs that's
steady state so this could also help us
understand viral tropism so why viruses
are infecting some cells and not the
other if we have these different basal
levels and we also can see that stem
cells are immunos responsive upon virus
infection and they do seem to respond
somewhat to interferon in our system so
this is a little bit different than the
in the pluripotent stem cell work that
had been done before this also could be
something different with stem cells
versus tissues and something that needs
to be investigated more so this is what
um a kind of a more visual version of
what it is so what you can see here is
that all the cell types have different
weapons so you have some that have
punching bags some that have bow and
arrows some that have knives and so all
of these cells are trying to get rid of
the virus and trying to fight them but
they're just using distinct Tools in
order to achieve this result
and so with that I would like to
acknowledge our bioinformatics team that
helped us a lot with this especially
Sergio from theater Alexandra's Lab at
emgl and all the other members of the
Standifer and bullet lab have who have
contributed to this work over the last
years and with that thank you for your
time and happy to answer any of your
questions